אנחנו חושבים שמחשבים קוונטיים יאפשרו לנו לפתור בעיות מסוימות מהר יותר ממה שאנחנו יכולים עם מחשבים קלאסיים לבד. אבל
להבין איך זה עובד זה עניין עדין. היום ב-Qiskit בכיתה, ננסה לחשוף את מקור העוצמה של
מחשוב קוונטי על ידי מבט באחד מהאלגוריתמים הראשונים
ממש. ברוכים הבאים ל-Qiskit בכיתה. בסדרה הזו נשתמש ב-Qiskit כדי לחקור כמה מושגים בסיסיים
שנלמדים בדרך כלל בקורסים הקשורים למחשוב קוונטי. כל סרטון מלווה במודול אינטראקטיבי
שמקושר בתיאור למטה. אז תבדקו את זה. אם שמעתם קצת על מחשבים קוונטיים, כנראה
שמעתם שהם יכולים להשתמש בתופעות קוונטיות כמו סופרפוזיציה, שזירה והתאבכות כדי לפתור
בעיות בדרכים שמחשבים קלאסיים לא יכולים. אבל איך בדיוק התכונות האלה עוזרות? ב-1985, David Deutsch היה
הראשון שהראה איך זה יכול לקרות. הוא המציא את מה שנקרא היום האלגוריתם של Deutsch שיכול לפתור
בעיה בצורה יעילה יותר מאשר אלגוריתם קלאסי. היום נסתכל על האלגוריתם של Deutsch
והרחבה מאוחרת יותר שנקראת האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa ונבחן איך ההיבטים הקוונטיים הייחודיים של ה-qubit-ים
יכולים לשמש לטובת המחשב הקוונטי. אחר כך נריץ את האלגוריתמים האלה על מחשב קוונטי אמיתי עם Qiskit.
יש אלגוריתמים קוונטיים נוספים שגם מראים יתרון תיאורטי על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים ידועים. ולא כולם עובדים
עם אותם עקרונות כמו אלה שנראה היום. אז מה שנלמד היום לא מסביר באופן כללי איך מחשב קוונטי
עובד, אבל זה כן עוזר לנו להתחיל לראות איך עקרונות מכניקת הקוונטים יכולים להשתלב כדי
ליצור מחשב קוונטי חזק. לפני שנצלול לאלגוריתם של Deutsch, בואו קודם נחשוב איך מחשבים קוונטיים
שונים ממחשבים קלאסיים ואיך זה יכול לתת לנו יתרון בפתרון בעיות
מסוימות. הבדל אחד הוא שהביטים הקוונטיים שנקראים qubit-ים יכולים להיות במצבי סופרפוזיציה. במקום להיות
מוגבלים למצב אפס או למצב אחד כמו ביט קלאסי, qubit
יכול להיות במצב סופרפוזיציה של גם אפס וגם אחד. אנחנו כותבים את המצב הזה
ככה, כאשר a ו-b הם מספרים מרוכבים שהריבועים שלהם מסתכמים לאחד, וככל שיש יותר
qubit-ים, הפער הזה גדל יותר. שני ביטים עדיין יכולים להיות רק באחד מארבעת
המצבים האפשריים האלה. 0 0 1 1 0 או 1
1. שני qubit-ים יכולים להיות בסופרפוזיציה של כל ארבעת המצבים המותרים קלאסית, שזה
נכתב ככה. באופן כללי, מערכת קלאסית של n ביטים יכולה להיות רק באחד מ-2 בחזקת n
צירופים אפשריים של אפסים ואחדות. מערכת קוונטית של n qubit-ים יכולה להיות בסופרפוזיציה של כל 2 בחזקת n מהמצבים
האלה. הסקילינג הוא אקספוננציאלי. אז גם אם היו לנו רק 10 qubit-ים, הם
היו יכולים להיות במצב סופרפוזיציה של 2 בחזקת 10, שזה 1,024 צירופים אפשריים של אפסים
ואחדות. הגידול האקספוננציאלי של מרחב המצבים של qubit-ים נקרא הקבלה קוונטית
ואחראי בחלקו ליתרון של מחשבים קוונטיים על מחשבים קלאסיים. אבל מחשב קוונטי
הוא לא סתם מעבד מקבילי ענק. רק בגלל שה-qubit-ים במחשב קוונטי יכולים להיות
בסופרפוזיציה של מספר אקספוננציאלי של מצבים, זה לא אומר שיש לנו גישה לכל המידע בכל אחד מהמצבים
האלה. מכיוון שמדידה מקריסה את המערכת למצב אחד או אחר, בואו
נראה איך זה מתבטא בבעיה פשוטה. נגיד שיש מכונה כלשהי
שאפשר להזין לה ביט בודד. אז היא תפעיל פונקציה כלשהי על הביט ותפלוט ביט בודד אחר. המכונה
נמצאת בתוך קופסה שחורה שאין לנו גישה אליה. כל מה שיש לנו גישה אליו זה הביט
שאנחנו מזינים x והביט שהקופסה פולטת f
של x. אנחנו רוצים להבין מהי הפונקציה f שהמכונה מפעילה.
יש ארבע פונקציות אפשריות שלוקחות ביט בודד לביט בודד אחר.
אז כדי לגלות מה הפונקציה, אנחנו יכולים פשוט להזין אפס ולראות אם היא פולטת אפס או אחד. אחר כך להזין
אחד ולעשות את אותו הדבר. כל אחד משני הצעדים האלה נקרא שאילתה. זוהי
דרך אחת להשוות אלגוריתמים קלאסיים וקוונטיים דרך מה שנקרא מודל השאילתות, שבו אנחנו משווים את מספר
השאילתות שכל אחד מהאלגוריתמים צריך לבצע לקופסה השחורה כדי לפתור את הבעיה. אז במקרה הזה,
השיטה הקלאסית שלנו הייתה צריכה לשאול את הקופסה פעמיים כדי ללמוד את הפונקציה. בואו נראה אם נוכל לעשות את זה טוב יותר אם יש לנו מחשב קוונטי
ששואל את הקופסה השחורה. במקום להזין קודם אפס ואז אחד,
המחשב הקוונטי יכול להזין לקופסה qubit שנמצא בסופרפוזיציה של אפס
ואחד. אז בעצם, אנחנו מזינים לקופסה את שני הקלטים בשאילתה אחת. אז
האם זה אומר שאנחנו יכולים ללמוד את הפונקציה עם שאילתה אחת בלבד?
לצערנו, זה לא המקרה. אנחנו רואים למה הרעיון הזה נכשל כשבודקים אותו על מחשב קוונטי. ניצור
circuit עם שני qubit-ים. qubit אפס שמיוצג כאן על ידי הקו העליון יהיה מצב הקלט X שלנו שאנחנו מזינים
לקופסה השחורה שמוצגת כאן על ידי ה-gate הבורדו שמסומן UF. ה-gate UF
מתוכנן לקחת את qubit אפס כמצב הקלט X ואז להפעיל טרנספורמציה על qubit אחד שלוקחת
את המצב אפס למצב f של x. אז כל עוד qubit 1 התחיל במצב
אפס, הפלט הוא x על qubit 0 ו-f של x על qubit 1. אז כדי למצוא f של x עבור
גם x=0 וגם x=1 בו-זמנית אנחנו יכולים לנסות לשים את qubit 0 בסופרפוזיציה של 0 ו-1 לפני
שאנחנו מזינים אותו לקופסה השחורה. זה נעשה עם gate ה-Hadamard האדום הזה שמשנה את מצב האפס ל-1 חלקי שורש 2
כפול 0 + 1. אז אחרי ה-gate של הקופסה השחורה, עכשיו אמורה להיות לנו סופרפוזיציה של גם
f של 0 וגם f של 1 על qubit 1. כשאנחנו מודדים את שני ה-qubit-ים, אנחנו מקווים
לענות על השאלה, איזו פונקציה נמצאת בתוך הקופסה השחורה. בואו נשתמש ב-sampler primitive של Qiskit כדי להריץ את
ה-circuit ולהחזיר את התוצאה. אנחנו יכולים לבחור את מספר הפעמים שה-circuit רץ שנקרא דגימות על ידי שינוי
הפרמטר הזה שנקרא shots כאן.